>> Tucker: SO MSNBC, THE TV
NETWORK NOT THE SCHEDULE THREE
PHARMACEUTICAL, HAS A BIRTHDAY
TODAY.
THAT CHANNEL IS 25 YEARS OLD.
IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE, ESPECIALLY
FOR THOSE OF US WHO REMEMBER THE
DAY WAS BORN.
AND YET EVEN AT THIS ADVANCED
AGE THERE ARE A LOT OF
MISCONCEPTIONS ABOUT MSNBC.
THE FIRST IS THAT ALL OF ITS
ANCHORS HAVE BEEN ACCUSED BY A
SITTING PRESIDENT OF MURDERING A
YOUNG WOMAN IN A CONGRESSIONAL
OFFICE BID THAT IS NOT TRUE,
IT'S A MYTH AND WE LIKE TO
DISPEL IT ONCE AND FOR ALL RIGHT
NOW.
THE SECOND MISCONCEPTION ABOUT
MSNBC IS THAT IT HAS ALWAYS BEEN
SOME SORT OF LEFT-WING
REVOLUTIONARY CHANNEL.
LEON TROTSKY TV.
THAT IS NOT TRUE EITHER.
FROM ITS FIRST HOURS MSNBC WAS A
CORPORATE PROJECT.
THE MS STANDS FOR MICROSOFT.
THE NBC, THAN A DIVISION OF
GENERAL ELECTION.
SO THE CHANNEL BEGAN AS A MERGER
OF BUSINESS TITANS AND
FUNDAMENTALLY IT IS STILL ONE
BIG HR DEPARTMENT.
AFTER THE 2004 PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTIONS, THE GENIUSES IN THE
PROGRAMMING OFFICE DECIDED TO
PREVENT AND MAKE MSNBC MORE
POPULIST OR SOMETHING.
THEY WEREN'T SURE EXACTLY WHAT
THEY WANT TO BUT THEY HIRED A
NEW PRIME TIME ANCHOR ANYWAY.
>> DO YOU WISH NOW, LOOKING BACK
THREE YEARS, THAT THE PRESS HAD
BEEN A LITTLE MORE VIGILANT IN
ASKING QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
INVASION OF IRAQ DURING THE RUN
UP TO IT?
LIKE ARE WE CERTAIN THERE ARE
THE STOCKPILES THAT WE ARE USING
TO JUSTIFY THE WORK?
HOW DID THEY KNOW THEY ARE
THERE, WHAT EXACTLY ARE YOU
TALKING ABOUT IN YOUR SPEECH?
DON'T YOU WISH THE PRESS HAD
BEEN A LITTLE TOUGH ON THE
ADMINISTRATION.
>> Tucker: HONESTLY, THAT IS
PRETTY COMPELLING TELEVISION BUT
IN THE END IT WAS NOT ENOUGH.
THE GUY YOU JUST SAW WAS FIRED
FOR LOW RATINGS.
HE WAS REPLACED BY AN
EMOTIONALLY STUNTED, AGORAPHOBIC
BASEBALL CARD COLLECTOR WHO WORE
MOM JEANS TO THE OFFICE AND
WROTE A SCRIPT WITH TOO MANY
ADJECTIVES PAID MR. KEITH OBER S
AND GENTLEMEN
AND KEEP IN MIND THE LETTER
ELLIS ISLAND.
BEFORE LONG HE TOOK HIS MOM
JEANS AND WENT BACK TO HIS SAID
MIDTOWN APARTMENT, BUT MSNBC ARE
MADE IN EVOLUTION CONTINUE.
LIKE PUPPIES, ALL TV NETWORKS
ARE CUTE WHEN THEY'RE LITTLE.
THE PROBLEM IS YOU NEVER KNOW
WHAT THEY ARE GOING TO GROW UP
TO BECOME.
WHAT IS MSNBC NOW?
ESSENTIALLY IT IS THE NETWORK OF
DRUMMING UP RATES FOR
YOUR TWO -- HE IS THE ANGER ONCE
AGAIN SCREAMING ABOUT THOSE
DIABOLICAL WHITE PEOPLE.
>> HERE WE ARE AGAIN WITH
CONSERVATISM AT LEAST AMONG A
CERTAIN COHORT OF WHITE GUYS
READING ITSELF AND THE IDEA THAT
EVEN DURING A PANDEMIC, THESE
SCREAMING MEN AND WOMEN HAVE THE
GOD-GIVEN RIGHT TO ORDER A STEAK
AT THE RESTAURANT AND HIT THE
GOLF COURSE AND THE BAR, AND
THAT THOSE RIGHTS WHICH THEY
CLAIM WERE CONFERRED UPON THEM
BY GOD, REQUIRE A
DISPROPORTIONATELY BLACK AND
BROWN LABOR FORCE TO RETURN TO
WORK, GET BACK ON THE WHEEL, AND
RISK OF DEATH IN ORDER TO SERVE
THEM AND RETURN THEM TO THEIR
COMFORTABLE LIVES.
>> Tucker: BROADCASTING THAT
CRAP 24 HOURS A DAY.
IT'S PRETTY UGLY.
BUT WE ARE GOING TO RISE ABOVE
IT TONIGHT AND WISH OF THE WOMAN
YOU JUST SAW, THE RACE A LADY
ALONG BUSH
, THE RACHEL MADDOW IMPERSONATOR
AND RACHEL MADDOW HERSELF A VERY
HAPPY BIRTHDAY AND WE WILL DO IT
WITH MAXIMUM CULTURAL
IMPERIALISM.
AS THE AVERAGE STAY ON OCCASIONS
LIKE THIS MAKE YOUR LIFE BE FULL
OF GLADNESS AND HEALTH ENTER
BUCKET FULL OF GOLD IS THE LEAST
OF YOUR WEALTH.
MAY THE DREAMS YOU HOLD DEAR BE
THE ONES THAT COME TRUE AND MAI